[Music]
in
esports as in life rulers are destined
to rise and fall sometimes a crown
naturally finds its way onto the brow of
an up-and-comer heralding
a new era of royalty as xy has to shine
through in a one-on-two he's got the
first
he's not in the second silence of god he
is above anything else's can create
other times it's left unattended and
gets seized
as a result
as the level of competition increases
those who've been deemed masters of
their craft are
faded to be dethroned kings come and go
and those who were adorned with laurels
yesterday aren't
likely to be imperators today that is
unless you're talking about adam
freiberg freiburg
csgo's unusurpable fruit obsessed
monarch
this could be a complete massacre here
get right picks up a crack they're gonna
commit their way through freiburg picks
up three in a row
make it for freiburg excellent defense
there on banana
fryeburg is a swedish entry fragger who
famously became a supporting cast member
in one of esports's
all-time greatest dynasties but that's
not
what he's really known for you see
freiburg is the only player to dominate
one of his game's most
infamous iconic and innuendo-prone
call-outs for nearly a decade
the only competitor to consistently make
banana
his [ __ ] now fryeburg he's taking the
bit of the fetish spot right here
and they're gonna try and flash their
way through this could be this could be
perfect
the double spray the triple spray
freiberg he ruins them
so how is it that freiburg managed to
cement himself as the so-called
banana king of counter-strike and why is
it a title that
no one's been able to take away from him
after all these years
they could ask for some bananas in here
as well i don't i don't see why not if
we have if we have if you feel if you
need bananas freiburg bananas you will
guess
[Music]
now if you haven't heard of the legend
that is fragberg
you're in for a treat when he's not
peeling tea brains in counter-strike's
sketchiest alleyway you might catch him
playing some shinny
making his guitar gently weep or
throwing unprovoked dance parties
[Music]
but between 2009 and 2011
before he was inferno's resident rush b
expert
freiburg had been making his name in
source
and after making the move to cs go in
2012
it wasn't long before the selfless entry
fragger caught the attention of the
game's first
veritable super team ninjas in pajamas
led by the legendary 1.6 born bromance
that is
forest and get right nip were the first
counter-strike roster to go
all in on global offensive after
recruiting one of the greatest in-game
leaders the original counter-strike had
ever seen
and one of the biggest names in source
they needed
a fifth nip could have picked anyone but
in the end they
settled on fryeburg i heard rumors that
get right enforced and exist we're gonna
start a new team with cs go
and i've been playing a lot with them in
games mixes and stuff like that
and i saw this is my chance to play with
them now
why was that surprising well freiberg
wasn't exactly what you'd call a
household name freiburg one versus three
we'll get the first one with the
headshot but it's gonna be really hard
for firebase because now
he takes that much now it's a 1v1 five
fryback
the guy many of you have blamed for not
being off the path
will clutch that round for nip the
question was who is fryberg when he
first joined up
because you have get right in forest
that was sucking all the oxygen out of
the room
and for good reason i mean you have the
two 1.6 legends who have jumped shipped
to this
upstart game cs go who's going to play
cs go it's a trash game
anybody can tell just watching it
fryeburg i think he grew into his role
as everybody got to know him everybody
got to learn
just who fryeburg was more importantly
freiburg wasn't your typical
aim obsessed entry fragger he wasn't
selfish or
individualistic on the contrary for as
long as he'd been competing he'd always
been fixated on helping his
teammates in whatever way he could like
i don't care about the stats
when i play i just want like my team to
win
i don't really care about how like i'm
doing of course
i want to play good i want to like help
my team win
but the stats for me it's just [ __ ]
like
you play as a team you win as a team
fryeburg was pretty much as sacrificial
as someone in his position could get
and that's what made him such an
invaluable addition to an
already devastating roster about to move
out into the balcony they're just below
us right now
you can now see them through the x-ray
here they come into the bombs like
completely nailed in the face by
fryeburg though
oh my goodness that went horribly
horribly wrong
with the addition of freiburg nip
quickly established themselves as a
force to be reckoned with
on top of racking up their now famous
87-0 map streak
they made it to the grand finals of the
first five
cs go majors from the moment when we
started playing in nip
we noticed how good we were from
tournaments and tournaments in 2012 we
didn't lose a single map
the important thing to understand is
that even though he was far from being
their star
player freiburg actually played a big
role in nip's success
why well for starters this man was a
true w warrior despite being as cold and
calculating as they come
the second he found an opening he was
capable of
tearing teams apart this is going to be
really crucial now what happens here in
catwalk
there's fryeburg fryeburg both
kills adrian comes in and frybreak with
three
this is it he gets the spray frybrick
they finally shut him down but it's a
one on three
fantastic play the entry fragger at his
best
i never thought of him as the heavy
hitter of the team i always thought of
him as the
follow me kind of leader right getting
in there like that's when you when you
say
that he holds down w and charges forward
and takes over it's just
okay now some we need to create a space
we need to create opportunity
and he is one of those classic entry
fraggers in the sense that
even if he isn't hitting shots he's not
going to let that slow him down in spite
of his inherent blood thirst
fryeburg was still known for being very
selfless
he wasn't interested in making flashy
plays he just wanted to win
and would do whatever it took to make it
happen so those c's get into the mix now
trying to
take him down actually it's freiburg to
get the first there takes out seized
if frybo falls with a second we said you
can't take these guys lightly but
that's quite literally the way to start
things off can you get the hatchery
though nice tag coming out gonna look
for the follow-up
zeus does go down as well and freiburg
with the hat trick already
they shouldn't be getting more than a
couple of kills here the most they don't
actually fry but look at a spray here
quad kill
all headshots all from us i don't think
nip can actually seal this round it
looked so good
just a few seconds left here seven six
selected fryeburg goes for the kill he's
gonna pick it up
if just exists of ice he's gonna win
around there's no time oh
my god frybook are you kidding me they
win the round because of it
they just need to two kills here and
they will win it for the second time
pronax with one frybra
oh my god he's freeze down he gets
now that's not to say he didn't
occasionally take his supportive mindset
a little too far
[Laughter]
anyway there was one fateful street on
which fryeburg stood as not only his
roster's ever helpful henchman
but a hearty harrowing hero one perilous
pathway where his penetrative talents
became particularly potent banana
this could be a complete massacre here
get right picks up a frag they're going
to commit their way through freiburg
picks up
three in a row make it for freiburg
excellent defense there on banana just
said you as you would expect
and now fryeburg is taking a bit of the
fetish spot right here and they're gonna
try and flash their way through this
could be per this could be
perfect the double spray the triple
spray fryeburg he ruins them
fryeburg gets four here we go probably
gonna get challenged king up and on he's
running the crown earlier and here he is
defending his throne
it's gonna be a pretty easy round again
only losing one man
okay so i know what you're thinking
what's the big deal
the guy is a beast at taking and holding
one area of
one map in the whole of cs go so what
well for starters being able to dominate
a crux position on arguably
the most important map in competitive
play is a lot more impactful than some
of you
silver scrubs might think all of the
great finals ended on that map
it felt like if you had inferno as the
third map in a series you were in for a
banger for you to be the particular king
a particular spot on the most important
map when it goes into a grand finals
all the pressure's on you and so when
you can show up and
and give that performance when your team
needs it most as well in a finals
absolutely it's going to affirm your
legacy as one of the greats on that map
but more importantly freiburg's
outstanding performances on banana
essentially one nip their only major
remember how i said nip battered their
way to five consecutive major grand
finals
well as it turns out they only managed
to win
one of them and it's only because right
as nip looked to be on the
verge of collapse freiburg decided to
make the ballsiest banana take
anyone had ever seen well meister will
find the shot on
exist fryeburg does return picks off
pronax he's still here though and he's
going for more
two big franks the third man is here
however and freiburg has to back off
but fry bark somehow opens it up
single-handedly
and this could be a turning point nip
that has got to be
shattering for fnatic and they bounce
back from being manhandled by fryeburg
and the master of banana certainly is
here only him
walking forward and getting all three
frags to open up that site
as dramatic as it sounds that one
epic unthinkable maneuver changed
everything what you've witnessed in this
tournament is a broken nip team managed
to resurrect themselves and exist picks
up two kills
forrest with the shot as well
olofmeister goes down and here it comes
two on 5 jw and flusher there is
nothing they can do any longer nip have
won
gamescom 2014 ladies and gentlemen
16 13. it finally happens
a year after nearly a year two second
place finishes them
finally claimed the title they are
the champions the highlight in my career
is the esl coulomb 2014 when we won
the major super good feeling it felt
like i was king of the world
but that's not the only crown that was
bestowed upon our swedish sidekick
coming out of cologne
from that day forward freiburg was
finally regarded as a star
in at least one respect he'd indelibly
been declared
the king of banana and man
did he run with it i mean yeah you all
saw the match right everyone here on the
stream oh i suppose
yeah oh my god you know the the molotov
i threw banana
and killed all five oh yeah that was
sick there weren't even any flashbangs
i mean i don't know what happened it's
like reverse banana split
the devs even paid tribute to good old
godberg during the inferno rework by
putting up a sign
at the top of banana that read adam
street
hell it was even turned into a flavor of
ice cream in sweden
obviously uh it was all jokes back then
but uh the whole point was that
it was so predictable that it was almost
it just had to be his kingdom because
that was where he was every round you
could have players where get right you
didn't know where he was going to be on
the map
but then you know you always knew that
fryeburg was going to be in banana on
inferno so that one position on the map
that was fryeburg's domain and if you
dared enter his domain
well he was ready with the headsman's
axe to take you out we'll see if the
stars are brave enough to hold it this
time fryeburg
the king of banana taking down device
right away
the problem of course is that at some
point fryeburg's play became a little
too one-dimensional and because
expectations were
so high for the famed swedish outfit the
supposedly over
ripe banana king began to fall out of
favor with his subjects
like 2015 was a hard year for me
um where i just i just sat and
told myself like i i don't want to even
sit and read what they're saying i'll
rather just
keep on playing until i can like smack
them back
by playing good right unfortunately for
fryeburg nip's form
continued to suffer throughout 2015 and
the team made the difficult decision to
part ways with their crown holder in the
hope that it would
improve their results although he was
gutted to leave nip
fryeburg quickly discovered that whether
he was with the team or not
wherever he went he was still regarded
as the king
of banana give him a warm welcome
the king of banana fryburg
now that's not to say that fryeburg's
crown hasn't been
scuffed from time to time
but he does occasionally remind everyone
that his reign wasn't
bought it was earned
anyway in 2020 after years spent apart
fryeburg was finally reunited with his
swedish super squad
on dignitas and while it remains to be
seen whether they'll be able to rekindle
that good old
nip magic it'll be a whole lot easier
now that their maniacal monarch is back
in the mix
i think the point that i had with nip
back then that was always so fascinating
about that team and that fryeburg was
obviously a big part of was the
esprit de gaugh that that team had that
team spirit that morale
that they always had each other's backs
that they were always a unit together
the five of them
seeing them all reunite together under
the dignitas brand i mean
i don't think that they're you know i
don't think that they're going to win
any tournaments but i think that it's
pretty damn cool that they are able to
get it back together again and that i
think that they are a team that can do
damage
look there are no shortage of sprightly
up-and-coming zoomers trying to make
big dick plays in the most phallic
shaped sector in cs go
and don't get me wrong some of them are
pretty good
we shouldn't forget the fact that they
struggled massively on their t-side as
well they're anticipating banana from
the looks of the guy
over here that rings out first
he's had enough he's going to keep going
through it he doesn't really care about
it
get him out of here but the reality is
that they've got nothing on fryeburg
why because like all great pioneers
he was the first the one who showed us
both how
integral and electric of a position it
is
to innovate the vast majority of the
meta that continues to surround it to
this day
make no mistake freiburg is still
the banana king of counter-strike and
according to the sign
he always will be nobody can take away
the
the the king of bananas crowd it's it's
on him
it's always gonna be him he is so long
as there's inferno there will be the
king of banana and that
man will be freiberg yeah you're not
taking away the title from the king it's
it's always going to be his along with
that banana ice cream
banana banana banana
any other ways to say that yeah i think
i think thank you
but between 20 2009
and 2011. i'll just say that [ __ ] it
that's a good line i like this one a lot
peeling tea party it's just so
[ __ ] good dude over ripe banana king
that's great plantain
the bomb god damn god damn